here we go
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the
corridor digital podcast it's so
pleasant that was beautiful yeah I
wasn't going to do the whole solo
without like a rhythm guitar or anything
I figured I'd spare you of that and now
I have a frog in my throat so welcome
back everybody today we have some very
special people on the cast we've got
Nico perringer of course
hi
hello we've got Jonah Kaplan
it was so formal Jake there's like about
150th episode people know who we are
right now this is a 172nd episode I'm
trying to start off with like a chill
Vibe we'll slip right into it and we've
got Jordan Coleman hello Jordan big fan
of me yeah and of course and of course
me
hi actually and Jake Watson ladies and
gentlemen hi Hi how are you you know
every every intro is different you never
know what you're gonna get and like that
dude who made the Bingo board for the
podcast
you never know what you're gonna get do
they think everyone might be a winner I
feel so seen
yeah yeah I don't know if y'all saw that
but uh this this
um
this guy on Reddit made a great little
post about the podcast and we shared it
um as well it was really cool
yeah you can see it on our Instagram
page Instagram see you're fulfilling one
of the things right now where you look
at your phone during the podcast it's so
it's fun it's really intense but the
sandwich is fun for five minutes uh dead
air while waiting for someone to find
something on their phone that was me
pulling up the bingo card right now oh
my gosh
um there is it starts with a guitar
we've already got that one checked out
we've checked check uh Jake are we this
formulaic are we this predictable no
it's kind of strange to be like uh I
don't know just like boiled down into
these little you know you know it's like
joining your friends again it's like
coming around the table you know who we
are let's try and hit all of them today
at least we're consistent well Ren's not
here to scream yeah and Matt isn't sure
to say what is it yeah you did yeah you
did I didn't never remember so just wait
for it yeah you did
it slips right in there subconscious but
sometimes he also goes up because he's
like yeah you did
character yes Nico blows his nose into
the mic yeah sorry yeah you know what we
need we need a kill button for you Nico
like I tried on my I tried to do like
the Tas on day thing where like you know
I back away from the mic yeah yeah like
Cherry Chocolate Rain yeah like that
yeah yeah
well Jake I just checked out the boxes
doing something that can only be seen on
the video version of the podcast
like we're like two minutes into it
already listen our start the the hero
video that I put for people on the
corridor cast page is the one where that
we were doing during covid and it starts
off with just me glitching out the whole
time where I'm like welcome back to the
corridor digital podcast
and then you all laugh and then I do it
again and it glitches again I think it's
the perfect summary of what we do here
yeah yeah hey so today's episode of the
podcast is brought to you by Jason
Bourne yes thank you born franchise for
everything you've done so you uh people
who watch our videos which is probably
everybody listening to this podcast
um you saw the the the the movie tests
that Jake has been starring in the
Batman one or Batman has disappeared the
Superman uh identity Clark Kent thing
the Spider-Man tray catch and there's
this other one that had been on our list
for a while and I just I really wanted
to do it but it was extra hard to do
which is the Jason Bourne disappearing
act
yeah this one required some uh
additional research before we went
straight into it
um such as doing a few other of these
formats beforehand and now that we've
gotten a little bit of a sense for what
it is now we felt like we were ready to
finally take this one on yeah so the
idea here is that at the end of the
first Jason Bourne movie Matt Damon as
he's walking away from the camera
disappears when a little like moped
thing drives in front of him at the same
time like people cross the frame it's
like oh where did he go he disappeared
he's a spy he's mysterious in reality
you can watch it in slow motion frame by
frame but you can see these literally
ducked and running behind this little
moped thing with like a windshield on it
it's like oh it's just right there
scooting along running out of the shot
and so like well can we do the same
thing with Jake can Jake like get
somebody's attention and then disappear
when like a car drives by and like I
think it's possible
but the thing is
you can't do it when people know Jake is
in town we have to keep it a secret we
have to smuggle Jake into Los Angeles
I'm gonna be notes to everybody that
he's here in the studio and then we have
to pull off this moment and then have
him disappear so it's very very
complicated and very intense we want you
know want to see if it would work and
also at this point everyone in the
office is very Savvy to like when weird
things are happening so we Enlisted the
help of Jonah
I mean this is the help of Jordan
actually we didn't no I was she was
actually surprised the help of Derek and
and of course Nick had to film all of it
and off we went yes yes and uh well I I
hope it was a success I mean I feel like
if you saw it already go if you haven't
seen it go watch it but I feel like we
pulled it off I mean
that's that's that's what I was getting
when we were bringing people out
um
and I think everyone even though
everyone is Savvy to me pulling these
experiments everyone is also Savvy to
playing along with them now
so we don't want to ruin your video
true yeah well I think we can tell when
you authentically yeah we had a
different approach to this one and I
think that was good we've kind of
everyone's gotten used to oh well Jake's
in town so now something's gonna happen
you know and I think it was the right
move this time to you know try and catch
everyone with their pants down a little
bit you know and and make sure that they
weren't already waiting for something to
happen now to be fair when we started
pulling people out one by one for a
mysterious walk down the street I think
some people were a little cued in but I
think that even with a little bit of
like what's happening no one had you on
on their mind in that moment I think
that really was the key to making this
whole thing happen so Jonah as as
basically the the piece of glue that
made this whole thing work what was the
method what what happened what was our
how do we hit people with this with this
setup here well I think the most
important thing was the way that the
idea came to be publicly right so we had
discussed on Friday I think was it
Friday we were like all right Jake's
gonna come in town let's how are we
gonna make this seem like a normal day
so
I told Jake hey in the morning meeting
ask me what I'm doing today and I'll
tell them the idea that we had come up
with and I think if we hadn't done that
if you had kind of come out of the bat
and been like all right so Jonah you're
filming that video right people will be
like yeah
Jake doesn't usually do that usually he
asks Jonah what he's doing and so you
kind of primed me and I was like oh I
had this great idea let's take everyone
out on the street and do a little
history lesson on the things that we
filmed out on the street and I think we
did it so seamlessly that it just kind
of glazed over everyone's minds and so
that was really the secret and then I
think we did this this thing and we had
kind of figured out a rhythm as we kept
doing it but really trying to kind of
like how a magician will you know wave
his hand here and do something here the
waving of the hand was asking them
questions about the street as we got
there because people started like it was
weird we've never gone out on the street
like that so they're probably a little
on edge and we started asking the
questions and Nico started being like
all right this is a points game you have
the number that uh you know guess the
number of things we've shot on the
street let's go and so suddenly their
minds racing and they're trying to find
stuff and they forget that it's a little
weird and so by the time we get to the
end of the street where we ended up
shooting the actual gag
people were so flustered and and just
kind of taken off guard that they
weren't ready and that was I think the
secret sauce to the actual thing and you
know you were more involved in um Jake
was more involved in the actual mechanic
of the the stunt or the you know the
illusion but getting them there was it
was really fun because
it was a challenge to make it feel
normal but we did what how many people
did we get like eight yeah we did like
seven or eight or so yeah eight or so
yeah there's a lot of people that's a
factory line you just gotta like it's
like am I gonna be outside for six hours
today just running up and down I was
sore I was literally sore because I was
going all day but by the time we're on
our eighth person like we had a down pat
and it was it was a well-oiled machine
well that's why I almost ruined it
remember you guys
for what I was invited you told me to
come here and I was like well instead of
waiting for them to come back for me
I'll be kind enough to go there but you
know the crazy thing is I saw the tent
and what's funny is I saw the tent and I
took a picture of it before I knew Nick
was inside of it because I was telling
my uncle when I was visiting him in
Texas I was like there's tents
everywhere you wouldn't believe it yeah
and then I pass it and then Nick is
looking at me with his lens and I'm like
what the [__] are you doing but it like
I thought he was just capturing like
people getting the questions wrong about
the video that you guys are doing yeah
Maddie
he gets so mad he goes what the [__] is
you doing here and I was like all right
yeah but then I get to the feeling why
are you so angsty
but then you're on the phone and I'm
like okay all right and it just all
happened perfectly I still didn't know
what the heck was going on well so so
what happened from your point of view
what happened so you walk by Nick and
you're walking up and I'm with uh Matt
yeah because I thought you guys were
discussing that girl which is what I was
told so I got my call and you know is
Jake taking my phone I put it on speaker
because we quickly realized that it was
not at all reliable to call their phone
and it was just better to call my phone
um but when did you walk up to us it was
around that point I was walking up as
soon as like Jake got on the phone did
you see Jake before you you heard him on
the phone so you walk up you're like
who's that yeah and you're listening and
it's Jake and he goes something
something something he goes but look
behind you and so then we all look and
you're just standing in there so in my
head I'm like you're not supposed to be
here this week and you were there and
then I think Matt was like he's gonna
get in that van isn't he or something
it just all happened really fast yeah
Derek rolled in real slow on that one
too yeah so I didn't have the whole
build up of the questions on the street
but I still came in not knowing what was
going on so to say maybe from so from
your experience what it was a little
jarring right so yeah I think if you had
been primed maybe it would you would
have had a different reaction though I
think it's still 100 words
jumped in the van or do you feel like he
disappeared
it looks like he disappeared but if Matt
wasn't in my ear saying he's gonna dance
yeah Jordan was cool with a guy in a
tent I think she would go along with the
idea that he disappeared
so cool guy intent normal day Jake's
gone you know what's gonna happen on
that street yeah it was good yeah the
duveteen was that was the the kicker
that was the sealer of the dealer yeah
we we realized very quickly that when I
would run behind the van you could see
my feet yeah so we put a little piece of
duvetine as a little skirt on the van to
lower the point of view closer to the
road and that I think there was two
things it was that and then it was
turning and walking away from the people
we were referring to as the mark walking
away from The Mark before then turning
around
and trying to jump in the van but Derek
was going almost 15 miles an hour in
some of those shots so there's some
really funny footage from the GoPro
angle on the other side of the van where
I'm all cool and collected and I turn
and walk away and then as soon as that
van hides me it's just panic mode to
figure out Orient myself to try to run
and get in this van with this very small
window where you can't see your my feet
and then to just jump in it and I was
just going for it I'm glad we used the
um the stunt pad because had we not put
that down it would have been
Swan Dive
yeah you didn't really have a choice
when the van was going that fast because
we we did a few experiments to figure
out okay what's the right speed and you
know how is this going to go we did like
three or four test runs before we
brought anyone out
and then once we kind of had it had that
dialed the pacing and stuff then we just
tried to stick with it
yeah Nico I'm curious from your
perspective as you know the kind of
you you were casting the spell on people
and then you were also going through the
steps eight times with people and it was
really important that you answered your
phone and you had that conversation what
was your experience uh watching this
done over and over again with different
people so there's always the moment of
like a little bit of panic when it's
about to happen it's like is it gonna
work
which was always really entertaining
um and I will say Jake when you were
like the one thing is I got to see Jake
do it eight different times and I got to
see his performance evolve as it went I
got to see it get you know more honed in
and like the turn in the walk was really
nice but eventually you would turn and
start walking in the direction the van
was driving and like for those you could
it kind of felt like you're just turning
to get ready to go into the van but
there's other times where you turn and
like it's a little bit more like you're
walking directly away from camera or in
the opposite direction and those times
it worked really well but I will say
that like
getting people to have to like do the
trivia of like locations in Corridor
really like people if people realize
they don't know our videos very well
and so I think that Panic like hit half
the crowd some people were fine and just
like you know dropped videos left and
right but some like Matt named like
three Jordan Allen one Jordan like yeah
he's my shutdown yeah it's crazy he's so
good at Smash Brothers but in terms of
trivia
this trivia was anything like his Smash
Brothers he'd be on top
yeah but uh I think for me the most fun
part outside of just doing the fake you
know crew cuts video was the the phone
call with Jake because
basically as the Handler of the mark and
you make sure they are looking in the
right direction they don't miss the
performance because something that
sometimes happened is like Jake you'd be
like you know look behind you and they
turn and they'd see him like Jake
and then Derek would start driving up
with the car and he'd be like look
there's one thing you need to know and
like you kind of you go into your
one-liner and then yeah like two or
three people at that point would stop
and then they'd look away from you
they'd look over their shoulder back at
the like yellow Amtrak building yeah I
don't know what it is like human beings
that make us like pause and like you
know is something behind me is something
about to happen I think people could
feel that energy and like once in a
while it has to like tap people on the
shoulder be like hey look back at Jake
and they look back at you just in time
to see the car pass and have you
disappear yeah we've all seen that we've
all seen that shot from the prank video
where the person gets pranked and then
they turn around or they look somewhere
else away from the person who's pranking
them for confirmation of the reality
that surrounds them effectively yeah and
that was a human instinct that we didn't
quite calculate for until it started
happening yeah see you need like the
thing to like like Hey look
you know yeah and then the other thing
with the phone was not like obviously
answering my phone in a way that
is meant for them to hear it you know
like answering it for myself and then
you being like is so-and-so there and I
thought at that moment people would be
like okay what's the joke but people are
a little more like yeah I I happen to be
here coincidentally I have to be here
what do you logic it's really that
wasn't like the thing that tipped people
off immediately and then yeah you'd
start talking to them and I think Matt
mentioned like I knew something was up
the moment you held the phone up to your
love so like oh so I need to hold the
phone more naturally out in front of me
so that's a good tip from that there but
yeah it was it was really fun and uh
yeah I don't know it's just a thrill
every time watching it happen because
sometimes Derek came in fast sometimes
he took his time like Jake you had to
improv your Jason Bourne dialogue
sometimes for a long time an awkwardly
long time you had to be yeah you're like
Spiel for like you won't be able to see
me once I disappear or whatever you're
saying you know yeah and it's a public
street so sometimes we had bogeys that
would come down and I mean the one of
the earlier ones I can't remember who it
was with but we had
we were right in the middle of it I
think it was Griffin yeah this bogey car
comes up and literally Parks right in
the middle between Nick and I and then
four Dudes get out and there's a there's
like a Chop Shop under the freeway right
there and so they're bringing in like uh
you know ruined cars and damaged cars
all the time and these guys there was
these guys next to us that were
replacing a door on this little sedan
and so Derek couldn't always get to me
at the right time and then that car
pulled up in front of us and I basically
had to reposition there was another time
where I was hiding behind that silver
sedan and or that silver SUV and the guy
who owned it came in and got in it and
he looked at me kind of funny because
I'm sitting there in this turtleneck
with my ear comes on and a backpack and
I just nodded at him and he just
whatever and he got in his car and drove
away but right I go oh crap he's gonna
drive away right as right as the the
Mark was walking towards us so I had to
Quick hide behind this much smaller car
right behind it and I was just tucked in
there I thought for sure you guys saw me
but when you're not looking for it you
know it's it's it's easier yeah and I
can't look around for you either because
then it gives it away you know same with
Jordan we just had to trust that you're
not visible now Sam
so the Sam was in the office and we were
talking about these ideas yeah and Jake
Sam knew what we were doing when we went
on that walk did he he did okay he did
play along a little bit but okay
authentically afterwards I were talking
about it so you know he's answering the
questions nailing all the films we've
shot in the street of course uh easily
he took the highest score of everybody
um
actually yeah probably started for
getting his own videos
um but when we turn on to Enterprise
because he didn't know where it was
happening he didn't know how it was
going to happen so he's just like
waiting for the trap to be sprung so
he's coming in with that and the moment
we turn on to Enterprise and start
walking down towards you know going
under the street there he's he was
actively looking for you he's just
searching every single corner and he
couldn't find you and he's like okay I
guess Jake's not around here I guess
it's gonna happen somewhere else so when
it turned out that you were behind him
that was authentic and that was actual
surprise and you know the car drove by
and you jumped in it which he kind of
knew was going to happen but he's still
got to just see it happen and that was
also a very authentic reaction there
okay good and I'm I'm pretty sure he
thought that I wasn't gonna be in town
you're you are correct actually he did
forget until okay something in the
morning meeting tipped him off which I
think was actually you saying I'm gonna
film the screw Cuts video oh because you
guys I kind of talked about yeah oh the
morning meeting yeah that was brilliant
yeah what was your perspective of you
know I know everything about what
everyone's doing I can tell that you
guys are thinking most of the time so
when when you were talking about it I
was like that's a really good idea and
in my head I was like I mean he wanted
you wanted Nico to be involved in my
head I'm like Nico's in my head I was
like Nico's really busy he's probably
not going to want to do this I swear and
then you did like you were bored and I
was like that's a good boss
so I was like okay like this is fun like
this video is gonna happen that's all I
thought about I legit didn't think of
anything because Nick in the last week
wanted to shoot a video but he was like
oh yeah Jake's not going to be in town
so I remember that and so I didn't think
you were gonna be here yeah cause Jake
had planned he had told everybody he's
gonna come into this to town this
weekend bought us tickets and they're
like oh we should film this and Jake's
like oh Wendy's birthday is actually on
that week so I'll just tell people I'm
actually gonna stay home and delay my
trip by weeks you know it's my wife's
birthday turns out Jake actually still
came into town
she's pretty cool she's pretty cool but
Jake has a I mean if you're watching
this podcast on YouTube you'll see that
Jake has a spot where he works and he
films from and
in the Monday morning meeting if Jake is
in Los Angeles well how can he appear to
be at home in Texas right so that was a
little yeah you kept your camera off and
I can't believe I didn't catch that
because you were like oh yeah I'm moving
houses so I can't put my camera on but
you are already in that house and your
camera was on the week before yeah it's
explaining technical difficulties and
the one person that doesn't have
technical difficulties is Jake he will
figure it out
every morning I didn't have my coffee
yet but I didn't know anything the only
other person I had to kind of get
involved which I only realized right
before the Monday morning meeting was
that I on the crew cut show it's me and
it's Austin and I hadn't talked to him
about it at all and I like took him into
actually Jake's like bedroom where he
stays when he's here and I was like
Austin just come with me before we have
this morning meeting I close the door
and I go I'm gonna say something that's
probably gonna make no sense to you at
all and he was like okay and I was like
I'm gonna present an idea that we've
never talked about
and he goes what is it and I go just
whatever I say smile nod pretend like
we've talked about it and he was like
what does this mean and I was like also
also I'm gonna be gone for most of the
day so you're gonna have to edit and he
was like what and I was like okay they
rang the bell let's go and he just sat
down he's like okay and Allison was like
the like second person we filmed with oh
yeah yeah the first person I felt like I
owed it to him I was like what's going
on here again
sick joke to have him do the edit all
day yeah I was just down at the End of
the Street having tacos
[Laughter]
yeah he was a great sport everyone
everyone did a great job and everyone's
reaction was very different who was the
most surprised or shocked her who did it
work on them the best I think you were
Jordan because I was an accident
nothing all morning nothing phased me I
think Jordan Allen was the most like off
guard but also I think that's the one
where your disappearance looked best to
me
um I think there's really authentic
surprise from Griffin and Delight from
everybody
um but your disappearance got cleaner as
it went on later and then other people
were maybe a little more clued in to it
being like a bit whereas I feel like
Jordan Allen had fully committed to the
the fake video that we were shooting by
that point like he was all because he
had his man had gone blank on him so he
was panicking
so he had completely completely
forgotten about any possibility of this
being a setup for a second kind of video
whenever he gets into an idea whether
it's on film or if he's working on
something he gets into it so he's got
that that talent to just be able to hone
in on something and I think that helped
a lot
yeah yeah yeah he lives in a Fantastical
World already
um and so I think when he sees
Fantastical things he just gets really
excited like I mean this in the best way
like he saw you standing at the end of
the street and I'm sure you just thought
this is gonna be great and then this is
like already he's ready well yeah
because like when he flips
he was already excited you know what I
mean he's like oh my God Jake said he
wasn't here he's here
and suddenly he knows that something is
gonna happen you know what I mean yeah
and that's that's the zone that Jordan
in my head maybe that the van wasn't
such a shock to me I was more shocked
that you're a turtleneck in the middle
of the day okay I was like Jake's here
and I'm like what the [__] is he wearing
did you guys know that Jake was actually
in the studio when everybody was coming
in for the Monday morning meeting I
think Christian said he got here like 9
A.M yeah so mainu just passed each other
because I was coming in from a flight so
I got in at like 9 30. yeah yeah did you
hear everyone come in I was hiding in
the podcast room right behind where
you're sitting oh brilliant because no
one comes yeah just laid on the floor
behind the couch well yeah the lights
were off and everyone filtered in nobody
goes in there in the morning so yeah
except me I just hid behind there I did
say hello to you well I knew he was in
there and I had to grab some stuff off
this desk and Jake had been like I'm in
the podcast room make sure no one goes
in so I came in I was like Hey Jake and
he didn't respond
is who it was I started like getting my
[__] together I was like I guess he's
not here anymore and a full like
legitimate like maybe two minutes fast
and I was like okay and I was just
grabbing myself and then he goes hey
Jonah
[Laughter]
I was like Jake I was pretty sure it was
you but all you had said was Hey Jake
and then you didn't say anything and I
couldn't confirm just from those
that it was you so I I stealthily stuck
my head up and around the corner and to
confirm that it was you because I didn't
want to blow it yeah I'm sorry I should
have announced myself
hey Jonah
scared the [__] up did you guys say
anything else after that or did you walk
out of the room quietly pretty much that
and then during during the meeting
everyone was gathered upstairs and uh
and Nico and Jonah and Nick and I were
all in a chat and Nico was giving me the
all clear for when it was okay to run
because I had to run down the street to
the van where Derek had parked it but I
couldn't let anyone see me so as soon as
I got the all clear I I sprinted out of
the room and then sprinted down the
street past the studio and thankfully
nobody was late or saw me
um yeah because otherwise that would
have blew my cover
yeah and nobody's at the windows looking
out yeah you know when you jumped onto
the Monday morning meeting you're like
hey guys
you got under control real quick but I
was like yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
so what we learned in this as we learned
in a few of the other ones and as you
learn in storytelling in general it's
this idea of misdirection that you can
it you can tell any story and if you can
say hey look at this or look at that and
then shift somebody's expectation that's
that's kind of a key through line that
works not only in these experiments and
these social experiments but it works in
general in storytelling and I think
that's an interesting element that I
think gets under utilized and under
discussed uh it's it's true with magic
it's true with storytelling
um but that was the one thing that
Freddy had taught me when uh we did the
first Batman one and he'd kind of
mentioned it you know and would when he
started to get into magic because
Freddie
as far as I understand it he's been
doing he knows how to do little magic
tricks
um
he's not like David Blaine you know but
none of us yeah but he can do I mean I I
don't know when he started doing this or
when he picked up this habit but I
remember you know like 10 years ago
being in the studio and Freddie doing
some hand trick and fooling people
um Magic Castle oh really is he a member
he's a pin carrying member wow so there
you go yeah because we did this one
video
like I don't know how long ago it was
but uh there was this one guy named
Benji dolly that used to work out of the
studio and
um they convinced him one time they set
up a bucket full of water
and used a broomstick to like hold the
water to the ceiling and then somehow
convinced Benji to take hold of the
broomstick I don't know how
what words were used but they were like
yeah I bet you can't get this down or I
bet you can't hold this up there and and
Benji's out was always ready for a
challenge so he immediately just jumped
on it without realizing okay once I'm
holding this up there
it's the only thing it's going to do is
dump on me
but he was so athletic he just like let
go of the broomstick and then grab the
water oh wow
um but it's the same idea you know it's
like you do everything except you talk
about everything except the thing that
you're gonna do
and then at the moment where the
person's attention is most attuned to
the misdirection that's when you that's
when you pull the sleight of hand
it's a similar thing here
yeah yeah it's humans are funny that way
you can really like get them invested
and focused on something
I think too it's worth saying like with
the reference that we're pulling from
like the Jason Bourne
film like you were saying you can see
him ducking down and like running and
you know I don't know what that would
look like if we made that movie today
but I have a funny feeling they would
have they would probably like Roto it
out and make it clean and make it
perfect so it's like a perfect illusion
and then like you never see him and like
I think that there is something to be
said for like not everything in a movie
has to be magic like when someone does
something cool sometimes they're just
running behind a bus yeah you know what
I mean and I think I didn't know that he
did that until when we started talking
about this idea about a year ago Nico
showed me that footage and pointed it
out but I'd seen the original a few
times and I never noticed before him
ducking behind that cart and running
away I knew that they did something
there but I just assumed it was a comp
out
yeah yeah well in that and if that's
what you assumed then the illusion
worked on you and it's like it's a
matter it's like an effort thing like
it sold the idea and like we sold the
idea to everyone and could we have done
it with like four cars and like you know
other misdirection and like could we
have done it at higher speed like maybe
but like at the end of the day we
created like an illusion that worked
yeah and it created an effect and it was
like this kind of line you have to walk
when it comes to like creating an
illusion and I think that what we proved
with that was that
it you don't even need to film it like
it works like it it is it impacts people
to do that and it does you don't need
visual effects you just need friends in
a van if you get a van
well you know what Jordan Allen was
saying he wanted to start a service that
will do that at parties for people so if
you want to exit a party really cool you
can just call your buddy with the van
and they'll just come in and you can be
like all right tonight was great
service it's a real thing you can do
we're enterprising into exit servicing
yeah where anytime you need to leave
somebody somewhere super cool like that
you just call us we come for you
yeah well that is the thing too it does
kind of feel like a little bit like a
kidnapping yeah yeah but that's cool but
like at the person's request it's a
little weird it's like did he just get
kidnapped but do it on purpose yeah yeah
one that we should try
is in the future is uh you know in those
in in all those Chase movies where they
have three of the same car
oh yeah you know we gotta try something
like that with a drone we have three of
the exact same car and then somebody has
to follow it and follow the right one
the movie ambulance yeah they did it
like perfect did you guys watch
ambulance oh yeah when they like paint
the car they painted it but they also
have like three red cars maybe we should
do that for our drone video
yeah car chase drone yeah like yeah
that's not a bad idea does it work to
have your the drive under an underpass
and have like the car change colors or
whatever
yeah or I have three different cars
drive out
yeah man can you do the swap you don't
need three cars just one
can you have like so you challenge your
friend to follow a car what they don't
know man maybe we shouldn't do this on
the podcast
too bad let's see you'll see who listens
to the podcast hey if you're if you work
at Corridor and listen to this don't
tell anybody else at Corridor about this
podcast
he's gonna hear it
don't tell anybody about this
um
so you challenge somebody to fly a drone
and follow the car and what they don't
know is when that car goes under an
overpass it's going to swap to a
different like somebody else is going to
take off in like the same color car yeah
and then you know at some point the
person with the other car comes back and
like walks up to the person playing the
Drone sale and be like hey I'm here he's
like wait what you're here I'm still
following you you know or something like
that and you could yeah you test that
out yeah that would be ultimate in an
ambulance they actually did one of the
swaps in the exact location where we
filmed uh photo real do you remember
that that's right yep yeah it goes down
there yep yeah they did it they so
that's another film location that we
that maybe they knew about
um but yeah in the exact same spot where
where Sam is chasing me in in that video
uh that's where they shot one of the
swap scenes in ambulance
um that would be cool we should try that
let me call them the ninja smoke bomb
effect yes which I don't think is
actually possible
that one is dang near impossible as I
see it currently to get a smoked puff
that big requires a pretty big explosive
yeah
you're pretty big explosive like not not
huge but like big enough that like it
becomes a little bit more limited
Logistics issue yeah we've all seen it
we've all seen it done you know in in
all these different movies over history
they the the they throw the smoke bomb
and then poof the person's gone yeah
yeah so how do you actually do that
without a trap door ah I was just about
to say trap door
you could you could try a trap door it'd
be pretty hard to fabricate a trap door
without anyone noticing though
I mean this one would have to be
elaborate we'd have to take people off
location for another production
and then if we're at a different
location
where we're filming something else
and then we do this while we're there
then it would work
so we've fabricate an entire production
okay
yeah two birds is one stone we have a
real production and then a secondary
production that's kind of using the
actual production
yes it's a good idea
yeah is there a part of you that wants
to edit that Crewcuts video into an
actual video you know
I hadn't thought about it until we were
just talking about it now
it would work like but I don't know if
it's like not many people got
enough like we could do it it's funny
now that we're talking about it on the
podcast and this is coming out after the
videos out so maybe we'll I can cut
together that footage it's pretty funny
like I would do it just for Jordan now
he's just like uh the whole time and
there's some great great things that we
filmed on the street so yeah maybe we
could do it I don't know I'll think
about it do you got what you were there
should it be a crew cut I think it'd be
a pretty funny crew cuts video it
doesn't need to actually be the video
that we're pretending it is but like
watching people attempt to film this
second fake video that we're filming and
with that context that this is actually
part of a bigger prank would be kind of
funny yeah we can do it we'll release it
yeah that'd be fun and then we can you
know show the little clip show the
things that we filmed and you could even
include the Jason Bourne thing at the
end yeah yeah okay hello
yeah yeah as long as you give it the
context at the beginning yeah it would
totally work no we should do it we spent
so much time out on the street like
that's what I think people watching this
Jason Bourne challenge won't really
understand is like each one of those
people I don't know took like 10 minutes
15 minutes each we did eight of those
and we had to wait sometimes it was like
by the end I was like tired dude like it
was it was a lot yeah because we were
also it wasn't as simple as just
bringing them out there it was like we
had to kind of do this song and dance
thing but it was totally worth it I
think we've really heightened these
challenges to a degree where it's like
we're getting into
like you can't just show up anymore you
know and do a challenge like you've
we've already we've Now set the bar very
high so I think going car chase is
probably the next logical step or
something crazy I think you know we had
talked about faking your death possibly
and seeing if that's possible you know
all sorts of things
going on do you remember that scene in
Sherlock when he faces they don't want
to traumatize somebody with a fake death
it's impossible
I didn't think about that we're not
gonna do that to anybody I know it's
ethically horrible and like we
definitely shouldn't do it but is it
possible is it possible yes it's
possible the anxiety that I wouldn't
trust anyone after that yeah that would
be too far so that's too far so in the
space between Jason born and faking your
own death we have a lot of room we have
a lot of yeah we can do a lot there it's
gonna be fun there's still a ton of room
in there
if you guys have any ideas leave a
comment that isn't that idea you can't
fake someone's death it's not good it's
tax evasion technically
um can you repaint a car quickly enough
to lose the cops yeah that'd be cool
that that would be a good one all we
would need is a Pursuit driver
and a closed course yeah the problem is
in La you you're not getting away
because it's the traffic so all of those
ideas would be really hard to do in like
an open Street you know how you get away
in L.A
as you go you take your on your Chase
you go to the airport
because the copters can't follow you on
the airspace oh really then you can get
a spot to get out on foot and go hide
there you go everybody why do you know I
mean that's the classic
wow I love that you don't have an Escape
Route no I have two from the cops you
just come out of me about faking your
death this is way more suspicious
look I think about like look if there's
a big earthquake and the water lines
from like the reservoirs to La broke
yeah and two three four five weeks
without water fresh water
how would you get out I'll tell you
actually I have thought about this
um I have a stockpile of water I do I I
get the five gallons so I have enough
water for at least two weeks now after
that is where it gets interesting and I
don't know your the answer to this
question but what I do know is that
there's no way you're getting a actually
I do have an answer to this
realistically
I don't know which version of like the
apocalypse you're talking about here
big earthquake big earthquake
you're getting out on foot there's just
no way that you're getting out on the
roads because everyone starts freaking
out
all the roads are gonna get jammed up so
you better have a method of
like just you just gotta you're gonna
hike out that's the only way so you
gotta have a boat unless you have a boat
you could try and get out by sea but
even then to circumvent all the way down
you would have to be such an expert
sailor like and be so prepared to do
that I think the only realistic way
would be a just be prepared and have a
bug out bag and water and then just
start hiking East like through and try
and go high so you're not going in the
desert you're desert the Mojave oh
literally you're not going to Valley
Jonah you're not going east Jonah so you
can't go easy straight East you go up
it's like you're going towards like West
Covina
unfortunately I think what is your plan
you seem like you have a plan Jordan's
just gonna go to West Covina
honestly that's Dustin
I thought about this too because I'm
like I feel like the quickest way of the
city is bikes in the LA River okay so
okay yeah I think that's like my plan is
you get on the paved River and you go up
that because you're knocking out north
or you just get out of the city first
like because you're not gonna have
traffic jams on the other River yeah
theoretically I mean if you don't take a
car on it but all the cyclists well
where does it end stop and go bike
traffic it's like God damn it L.A
doesn't it end in like um Santa Clarita
when the uh the LA River probably
because that's the problem though is
like Jonah posed this question which I
think about too is like but to the east
it's all desert to the South it's all
desert to the north it's mountains in
this kind of desert I mean I get you
know there's all those Farms there but
it's like that's all irrigation and
stuff you know so it's like
it gets really tricky pretty brutal the
thing is like a long way going through
the Central Valley because especially if
there was if if you're talking about the
situation you're talking about which is
where the uh the reservoir is broken
um all that is is watered by that same
system
yeah so it you know I've driven across
there and it's on a motorcycle and it's
and
you know it's I don't think you'd want
to walk across that I did some so I have
a solar kit for camping that I use like
charge up my one wheel and bikes and you
know like runs on wheeling bikes and
whatever you know the gangs bikes and
one Wheels
um I did the calculations and that'd be
enough to get me like 20 to 25 miles on
my Tesla with a full day of like solar
okay so that's like maybe if like if for
some reason the roads are clear but
there weren't wasn't gasoline I could
you could travel during the night yeah
and charge during the day and travel
during the night and charging the day
and I could do it 25 miles at a time oh
my but I'd be in the car yeah we gotta
watch out for Raiders yeah I know yeah
but honestly going at night is kind of
smart because it's like the Raiders
they get scarier at night Jim you think
it's scary but don't forget if they're
scared they're just as scared of you at
night as you are of them yeah and you
were in a car sure yeah you know what I
mean with like a bazooka probably oh is
that a new bike I found it on the way
when I was traveling
it's your store you can write whatever
it is yeah it's like not going anywhere
an option it is that's probably the best
time I honestly think like shelter in
place is probably in the event of an
earth a major earthquake earthquake that
took water out for two months probably
shelter in place would be your best
option but I would just immediately rash
in water yeah yeah and just try and
figure that out but
you need the water in the first place
that's the tough part yeah the thing is
they realistically there's probably a
way to get fresh water from the ocean
that could at least keep people
sustained in La you know how
whether it's boiling it or evaporation
or something like that can we try you
can't really because I'm trying salt
water yeah you can
yeah the salt stays in the pan the water
evaporates it's just incredibly
inefficient yeah it's very super yeah
you're talking about a still
yeah yeah I've been talking about this
yeah a still would work but it would
would only give you so much right but
when it comes to just having drinking
water I feel like I mean there's enough
coast and there's enough people that I
feel like you can make it happen yeah
that's true we could start doing that
type of people are already scary enough
as it is yeah
you would think it's already happened I
couldn't imagine if it already happened
oh my God I always thought so where I
grew up is is really far north in New
Hampshire very high like East and they
they were doing nuclear testing up there
during the Cold War and though my town
the way that it's structured is the only
way in or out is through this Valley we
call it like the Notch and Legend has it
that they installed explosives on either
side of the notch so that if there was
any sort of nuclear leak or any problem
they could blow the Notch and trap
everyone in and it was like they're like
fail safe for if things went bad the
only way
out would be through Canada and so we
always thought like growing up we had
this like existential dread of like this
happening like we would we would talk
about it growing up like what happens if
they blow the Notch
and we would all talk about it would be
like all right well we'll go to the
highest peak we'll set up camp up there
be able to like send flares out from
there like it was like it was like our
Boogeyman growing up for some reason so
I never thought about the problem of
being like all the way
out west it presents a way different
issue because I feel like I'd want to
get to the Midwest you can just drill a
well and have fresh water I don't know
if you can maybe control a well here I
don't know if you can I mean that that
also eliminates thing you might hit oil
first you might be right actually I
don't know about the groundwater in L.A
yeah well now with all this rain there's
probably some but who knows yeah yeah
well you know like if if something
happens like that you fill up your
bathtub if you can oh with the late
depression of the pipes you just really
put that all in your bathtub and you
just that's a tank of water that you
have on demand now yeah just get get the
five gallon jugs too they're super cheap
yeah and you just have a stockpile of
those yeah or just get to the studio
there's about 20 of them there that's
true Jordan does she does this weekly
workout how often do you do it
too often how many how many are there
that you do it's crazy it's like 20 at a
time sometimes I think that's where my
biceps came from I promise you it's not
the gym sometimes I'll help and I'll do
like two and I'm like damn I did a good
thing today for Jordan and then I think
like bro there's like it's me coming 15
of them yeah wow yeah I do God's work
that's right this whole studio only runs
because Jordan's here
pretty much
yeah I mean a Bunker's not a bad idea
when you buy a you guys are homeowners
have you guys thought about just adding
Jake I just feel like this is something
you've started working on I mean I feel
like down here is a better bunker like
this building is a good bunker yeah yeah
you got a brick wall with like raised
Windows like this is this place is a
castle you know
so yeah that's why that well that's why
I moved to this small farm because just
in case in and of itself it's a bug out
bag in and of itself
yeah I wouldn't go anywhere if all that
happened I would just stay I would
shelter in place because you have a well
too yeah or yeah but there is some real
risk of the wells drying up
um it has hap it depends on where you
are
with respect to the water reservoirs
obviously but it has happened at a few
places around here you know there's
always that existential fear of oh well
your well is going to dry up but I have
a buddy down this down the road Logan
Logan Stark oh brcc yeah he he's only on
Rainwater
oh really oh yeah so he he has you know
uh gutters all around on his he's got an
auxiliary Barn in his main house and
that all goes into the storage tanks so
anytime it rains
and you can collect water pretty quickly
that way and of course it rains a lot
more here than it does there
um but he did run out of water last year
because he only had one tank
um so he put in another one
but that's the main threat here is just
the lack of water especially with all
the people moving to this area
and the other thing that I've been
learning about is how important the the
grass is to the groundwater and the
aquifer and there's always this tendency
to go oh well you know if we're gonna
build something we should figure out a
way to like control and divert the water
but what you actually want all that does
is gather the water together and make it
more stronger and send it away from
wherever you are faster so it actually
works against the ecological
implications if you put grass down that
grass catches the water slows it down
and then sends it back down into the
aquifer rather than sending it away from
where you are
um so I wish more people knew that here
because there's a lot of development and
the the common practice is to just well
divert the rain water somewhere
um as opposed to put that into the
ground yeah yeah but that actually is
kind of the opposite of what we could be
doing
so yeah
I don't know it's been interesting I've
been learning a lot and I had these same
thoughts when I lived in La too I had
you know I had a I had a bug out bag and
that was pretty much my plan you know
you you're the lightweight AR with a
light backpack and you just walk
yes what else can you do yeah you get
the lifestyle I'm just walking to San
Antonio I guess yeah you're there and
you just go to Beverly Hills and just
you know do a Bill Murray and just try
and
Slug and Zombieland just find the nicest
house
yeah that's your fun let's go to
Calabasas yeah they're set dude when I
lived um in high school when I was in
India we lived off rainwater on the
mountain and they have monsoons there
and uh so you would see these tanks
everywhere you could probably fit three
of them in here they were that big boom
boom boom these big black tanks and
every like they were everywhere on the
mountain and because the monsoon would
last for months at a time they would
literally swap them out too like they
had so much rain like it just rained
straight for for months like
it was so moist that if you didn't put
newspaper in your drawers your your
clothes would mold oh man like over yeah
it was absurd wow and then during the
summer you would use that water but we
had monkeys and uh I was I was on top of
the mountain uh there's like this it's
called chucker on the top where there's
like a couple restaurants and uh I
watched a baby monkey fall into one of
those a lot of things and it was one of
the most ethically fascinating
situations I've ever seen because you
had this baby monkey that fell into it
and the mama monkey was freaking out and
was trying to get in there and there was
a bunch of men who saw it happen and
they're like all right let's dump out
this jug so that we can get the the baby
out but the obviously the monkey didn't
understand that the mother monkey so
she's fighting these dudes who are
trying to do this and it took so long it
was so fascinating to watch they're like
fighting off this monkey trying to
trying to push it over and the monkey
would come back and they're kicking it
they finally got it tipped over but by
then like a couple minutes had gone by
and you just saw this Monkey kind of
slide out and the the mother monkey ran
over to it grabbed it up it was a limp
and she's dipped in the woods and I was
like damn wow in what sex is because it
was because of a man-made creation yeah
like we created this problem and then we
were trying to fix it and I don't you
know maybe the monkeys are fine maybe it
died I don't know but yeah there's like
a lot of impact from all the methods
that we try and solve the water problem
from yeah and it's like it's just brutal
to see like
at the end of the day like we kind of
created a problem by like creating these
like really advanced cities and whatnot
and like pushing all the nature out and
we thought that was like a really good
idea but then when we try and solve it
by say like getting a bunch of rain
water tanks and then suddenly like
nature starts interacting with it and it
becomes like a problem again
um it's convenient it's a balance it's
definitely a balance I mean you can't
you know if if it wasn't for those rain
jugs it'd be a human baby but it'd be
dehydration instead and it's
it's like what do you
what do you do you gotta you gotta
balance it
but anyways yeah just like when we shot
Jason Bourne
that was a really solid like tangent
right there yeah that was a good
challenge and I'm glad we got onto that
one that's what I like about these
podcasts yes you never know what's good
you never know what we're gonna be
talking about at the end what was that
one we did the other day where we were
talking about clay
claymation in the Pinocchio and like
clay stock like I got these 10
Pinocchio's in my basement
oh man
um
yeah so you never know where we're gonna
end up but um I don't know I think
that's that's this one
yeah yeah all right ladies and gentlemen
what a podcast yes time for us and
joining us once again and uh well if you
haven't seen the Jason Bourne episode
please go watch it and let us know if
there's some other tropes that you want
to see done in this experiment maybe
we'll try that underpass one yeah no
we're definitely not gonna do that
definitely not sure no we're not doing
it no Griffin we're not doing that one
we would never do that we shouldn't hire
Brie Lynch yeah
we won't reach out to her yeah no
definitely not
perfect
[Music]
thanks for watching everybody have a
great day bye
[Music]